I have a tweet from Carl Benjamin
because he had a great one so we have
the statement from the FBI on Twitter
they say breaking uh the FBI responds to
the Twitter files claiming that their
own leaked Communications with Twitter
are misinformation to discredit the
agency they said it is unfortunate that
conspiracy theorists and others are
feeding the American public
misinformation with the sole purpose of
attempting to discredit the agency Carl
Benjamin of the Lotus Eaters podcast
says oh I forgot that I was just a
conspiracy theorist and the FBI didn't
collude with Twitter to suppress the New
York Post Center Biden laptop story that
I watched happen in real time and then
read the files which show them
discussing it My Lying Eyes keep
deceiving me this is this is real life
okay it's it's unraveling we know they
did it we know they're doing it we have
the proof they did it and they're just
coming out and lying saying they didn't
do it it's buzzwords misinformation
conspiracy these buzzwords I'm kind of
getting fed up with these buzzwords the
buzzwords that's what they do they they
throw in these words this misinformation
these conspiracy theorists just to try
to cover their own asses and not not do
anything about it because they know
they're wrong and they know they're in
the wrong but I love how uh Luke often
brings us up too that conspiracy
theorist was a phrase created I think
Tucker talked about this that the phrase
first emerged in the corporate media
around was it JFK JFK yep and now the
FBI is is using it to discredit
legitimate emails from Twitter leaked by
the CEO of Twitter to a variety of
reporters showing the FBI not only were
they instructing or giving guidance on
who to censor but they were paying for
it my favorite component of the story is
that uh you know we're going to mention
him again Oliver Darcy the media
reporter for CNN reported no the FBI
didn't pay Twitter for censorship what
they were doing was reimbursing Twitter
for the for the labor costs of that's so
nice fulfilling government requests I'm
like this is what I talk about when
they're sitting there and you're like
um you know Mr FB agent is there a door
on the front of the building or know
Twitter's a better uh Mr Dorsey does the
Twitter headquarters have a door oh no
it doesn't there's no door no there
isn't how do you get in there's a portal
that's that's the game they play so this
is what they're doing right now no the
FBI didn't pay Twitter they reimbursed
them for the labor costs of acquiescing
two government requests
so they paid them they gave them money
this is the perfect way to understand
that uh almost everyone is in an abusive
relationship with their government this
is the the perfect example of
gaslighting uh double speak 1984 bull
crap that they're just putting out there
and what do they think they're going to
achieve here I mean obviously more and
more people are seeing the Twitter files
they're seeing the documents they're
seeing the evidence for themselves
they're listening to it they're they're
seeing it with their own eyes and right
now the state is telling you don't
believe your own eyes don't believe your
own ears don't believe your own mind
believe us that's the level we are at
when it comes to the propaganda that
we're dealing with that's a very
dangerous level for any state it's a
political Amber Heard like I got a
murder she's like she's like I didn't
punch you I just closed my fist and hit
you like what Kyle after you've
experienced with the Kenosha experience
something that it probably less than you
know one trillionth of percent of humans
have experienced stuff like that or very
very few Americans experience what was
your like what's your perception of the
government before and after and weren't
the feds lying and keeping data away
from your current trial let's talk about
that for a second though so the FBI they
had aerial Drone footage filming my
trial film not my tryout they probably
were doing that too but with the event
of that you were involved in my uh the
incident that happened they were filming
it with a
um with the aerial plane and they had
thermal imaging I don't know if you
remember that and they gave us a like we
we knew it was out there they refused
they had a they had a guy come in that
was
operating the camera sorry I'm just
trying to remember this correctly he was
operating the camera and then he was
testifying my attorney asked him what's
the tail number on the plane because we
had it and then State's Attorney comes
up nope we're objecting like here's his
Tui letter like pulled him off they
refused to air it I don't know if they
aired it they refused to error it to my
belief they didn't want him to have his
name out there and he couldn't be on
camera and I was like what what is the
government doing what is the FBI his
whole testimony was thrown out the judge
was like okay the jury has to like they
can't use anything he said
and we didn't they also had a drone
video and they gave us a decom
decompensated decompressed version
decompressed version of that while the
state had the enhanced version that's
what the but the enhance I remember that
like the enhancements was like a
computer manipulation yep absolutely
like they were crazy they were adding
data to it and then we found out because
the the the the the portly uh lawyer I
believe it was when he showed his life
sucks is that is that his name he had a
yeah oh James cross 88 cross oh he's got
his head on his computer he had a
program yeah he had a he had an app
called handbrake on his computer which
decompresses files and makes them all
blurry like that okay it not decompress
it compresses compresses right so so it
goes from high resolution to low
resolution and then makes it hard to see
what's going on so was this the state
prosecutors denying the evidence or was
this uh the FBI and this was the FBI
trying to clear the record in order to
exonerate you no the FBI was the FBI was
not trying to clear the record to
exonerate me the FBI was after me
um this was the state working with the
FBI a
to to try to pretty much throw me in
prison the rest of my life but why
you know because that's what those are
BLM supporters symbolic I think it would
have been smaller it might get yes you
saw the photo of the FBI agents taking
the knee during the black lives matter
protest that should tell you a lot it's
a cult they're a cult too isn't there a
photo of the director of the FBI with
like a Biden mug out there somewhere I
thought I saw something is that the
former FBI driver I wouldn't be
surprised I mean this is the same year
where we learned of all the uh how many
FBI people were involved in the Whitner
Whitmer oh yeah kidnapping but all but
two or something like that you know it
bums me out because you know in my mind
growing up the FBI was this this quirky
conspiracy theorist who believed that
aliens existed you know and then he'd
reluctantly tell his boss he tell his
boss who then reluctantly would call an
FBI teams to actually be forced to
investigate crimes and they never wanted
to believe him but then you realize the
FBI actually forever you know since J
Edgar Hoover was just like a political a
political weapon there's definitely a
picture of Comey wearing a Biden Harris
shirt with a Biden Harris mug drinking
coffee but he was out after like he
wasn't he wasn't he was already out of
office at this point he got fired but I
mean I think the crazy thing is what
we're learning now with Trump is that
while he was President the FBI was
engaging in these psychological
operations to discrediting the hunter
button laptop story with Twitter and all
that stuff they're now lying about it
and the funnier thing is guys I mean
come on Donald the left keeps saying it
but Donald Trump was in charge he was
the president and it's like not like
they were listening to him but at the
very least couldn't Trump have have done
something I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
blame Trump for being the victim of this
this political malfeasance or whatever
but when you're the president yeah you
gotta you gotta go through this stuff he
should have fired everybody right away I
understand the Russia gate stuff jammed
him up and tied his hands and all that
and that was the intent but Trump could
have at least known what they were doing
with with social media he he should have
known they were Banning his biggest
supporters and trying to affect the
outcome they're trying to affect him
politically did he say he was going to
break up the FBI if elected again he
should I'm I'm all for that you should
say that yeah that's what that's what
JFK said
and then well yeah and that was also
that's post Northwoods yeah oh man North
the woods if you don't know what project
Northwoods is it's definitely something
worth looking up because it's a great
conversation starter especially
operations in 30 seconds what is it in
30 seconds false flags on American
children Chiefs of staff's essentially
planning a false flag uh on the United
States in order to get us into a war
with Cuba this is the problem I'm having
is that domestic terrorism is good for
business for the FBI and the CIA because
it gives them something to do so that
gives them a reason to hire more agents
and to get more funding which is why I
keep thinking like if we get rid of them
which I want to those people will just
be like terrorists roving the country
but what do we wouldn't we just have
another secret police step up if we got
rid of ours it's probably inevitable but
we have to start over but but you know
the people need look
governments the idea of the idea of of
power coalescing just inherently means
corruption forms corruption will happen
and then the people need to come out and
say okay we're choosing now to to shut
the corruption down it takes willpower
and then when you weed out that
corruption the American Revolution for
instance they say to the king no we're
done and then they they say weed that
out we get the foundation of this
country and a couple hundred years later
we now have very serious corruption in
this country it's going to take in my
opinion fifth generational tactics
meaning influence building uh shows like
this people watching spreading the word
to their friends that's the path towards
success right now and when enough people
come together
and then say no more to this corruption
the system falters and I think that's
what we're witnessing right now with the
exposure of all this we're watching it
crumble this is the revolution this is
the populist Uprising in order for
corruption to keep happening you need
the confidence of the people that people
need to fear you they need to believe
that if they speak out they'll be hauled
off to the gulag but right now we're
starting to see a fifth generational
version of that scene from V for
Vendetta where the the inspector is
saying and then someone will do
something stupid and it shows the finger
man with the badge shoot the little girl
and then all the people just go and just
like start walking up to them like they
don't care anymore we're getting the
point where where people are starting to
feel more and more confident about their
ability to survive while defying the
machine the machine has lost the ability
to scare people it's got it first to a
certain degree we need more people to
just say something as simple as this I
don't care what you have to say anymore
I'm gonna do my thing and we're watching
that happen and the end result I think
is something very very positive when we
talk about you know the the uh the
fourth turning we're in the the end
stages it's supposed to get crazy this
could be it it may not be as bad as
World War II or the Civil War or the
American Revolution it may just be that
the economy gets a bad there's
hyperinflation maybe the dollar tanks
were arguing on Twitter because it's
fifth generational it's it's information
War so maybe all we have to do is
shatter the confidence in these systems
and then eventually when someone comes
knocking your door saying I have a
warrant you go yeah no one thinks your
agency has any has any Merit or or any
more so no one cares what you have to
say like there's that we're going to go
to this court this court has said your
your your warrants are worthless we just
don't listen to you so I keep saying
this is like we're in an existential
Renaissance like I see so many people
who were in The Matrix you want to put
it that way who kind of woke up during
covid and they were like whoa you know
they were not politically active at all
and now they uh they're completely just
out of it you know they want to learn to
grow their own food they want to take
their kids out of school you know and I
think that was
completely out of their world two years
ago Tim Robbins was red pilled I guess
you call it the great red pilling of Tim
Robbins he says like I feel horrible
about the way I demonized people that
didn't get the fact that's commendable
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time